o amor
ele foi o nosso vizinhos como salvar
mais de três milhões e meio de pessoas
em todo mundo foi para que começamos e
foi pra que construímos este projecto
não se salva importar em alguma idéia
contrária animal como e que foi
referenciado será uma cobra ou várias
como natural será o william ao homem por
fará exatamente ao ver o animal mais
mortífero que exista é o raio do
mosquito é tão pequenininho né e fácil
tanto mal não se tinham essa obsessão
mas são muitas muitas mortes todo ano é
todos os anos a olhar ainda este ano
estamos com uma a um agravamento é a
nível de taxas em todas as partes
então mais ainda significativamente em
áfrica a causa do problema da malária e
sobretudo também por causa da dengue no
brasil existem muitas espécies de
mosquitos são pequenininhos animais
coisa muito pouco que nos ocorrem também
alguns mícrons de sangue e que tem essa
particularidade do mesmo ao fim do ano
os ovos permanecem inertes e conseguem
chutar mesmo o fim do ano desde depois
apareça a água o mosquito agora quero
charcos como sabem ou a relva e ea
partir daqui eu ainda são próximas
coletivos ou seja o órgão para todos nós
e dizem uns são mais atraentes do que
outros né
ok qual é que eu vou escolher para picar
são os bandidos por cento
depois ainda não conseguem identificar a
distância ou seja 25 30 metros e os
primeiros assim é que eu vou atacar
então é patinha tanto na minha volta
porque eu vou escolher aquilo não é eu
tenho essa obsessão e saiu da ação
o que nós pretendemos é qual foi este
processo construtivo e por qual o vôo
chegará ão resultado final é que este
flagelo da malária da venda uma nova
variável que agora surgiu também de
chikungunya muito frequente nos países
das caraíbas e que entretanto frutas
mutações e das ligações também já temos
não é que era que a europa quer na
áfrica
começa a ser tamanha em grande escala
nesta espécie transmissão e também temos
a febre amarela é menor é melhor fiscal
somos são infectadas todos os anos mais
de 400 milhões de pessoas em todo o
mundo tanto ao inter das três milhões e
meio de mortos não é 400 milhões de
pessoas são infectadas
o organização mundial soube gasta todos
os anos mas 100 bilhões de dólares no
combate a este tipo de patologias
só que o que acontece nós estamos sempre
atuar na consequência é depois do mal
está feito e vamos atrás
então o nosso propósito em termos de
desempenho foi porque não vamos atuar na
prevenção porque não vamos nos precaver
para que isso não aconteça então
chegamos a uma solução
esta solução é sentar em uma tecnologia
que nós descobrimos essa tecnologia
consiste numa bateres de nanopartículas
que permite transportar princípios
ativos e os princípios ativos no caso
conferem propriedades diferentes
materiais de forma que nós consigamos
funcionalizar são um exemplo disso
vários materiais que eu já vou falar em
seguida
isto permite é esses materiais conferir
lhes uma elevada durabilidade e chamou a
atenção aqui por exemplo num aspecto se
nós conseguirmos funcionar usar uma peça
traz tela
nós conseguimos passar a um processo de
ao fim de 5 nas lavagens para ter esse
feito né colocou foi consumido
inicialmente onde nós conseguimos é
levar esse feito até as embalagens
nós conseguimos as selvagens em até 75
por cento de eficácia em lavagem
industrial o que significa que se nós
levarmos domesticamente nas nossas
máquinas
esse foi ainda vai procurar há mais
tempo
trata se dum de uma solução que é amiga
do ambiente
é um produto ecofriendly nós preservamos
o ecossistema porque também com ray de
inscritos também são precisos para
outras espécies na época outros tipos
servidos como isso o que nós fazemos não
utilizamos inseticidas os inseticidas
são altamente tóxicos prejudicam
gravemente
nessa lula em contacto com o papel nossa
salvar a empresa atingir o e fluence o
cantor bell oito vezes
é muito nocivo é absurdo também com as
crianças porque eu só podem ser
utilizados a partir dos dois ou três
anos e também podem ter mais tarde essas
crianças que toquem né em produtos
anicet sida podem ter problemas também é
prático
no nosso caso o produto pode ser
utilizado a partir dos seis meses virado
e isso também é uma grande diferença
nós temos aplicações diversas temos no
país caiu tanto no produto novo produto
já existente é termos aditivos para
tintas e vernizes
imaginem o que era entrar agora uma
andada mosquitos nesta sala
ora a proteção cada um tinha estávamos
créditos através das nossas roupas
o ambiente em termos de espaço estava
protegido ou não estaria nem as
consequências teriam graves
mais tarde a mostrar um vídeo onde vocês
vão presenciar essa situação nós aqui
temos um efetivo que colocamos nas
tintas vernizes e conseguimos conferir
esta ambiente uma propriedade no
possível após mosquitos por um período
de quatro anos quer seja interno ou seja
também a pintura pode ser tamanha
externa em termos de tramitar com
finalizamos os vasos porque os vasos no
momento é o sítio onde eles vão deixar
os jovens para se reproduzir com isso
conseguimos que haja menos produção e
evitar também que haja ficava como é
natural também funcionou usarmos relva
sintética também sabemos que cada vez
mais utilizar você entende que não é
algo natural e não sintética porque é
porque os mosquitos gosto muito da cara
nos tornozelos
é importante se tivermos uma proteção
animal da relva com meus adoro muita
relva também dos conflitos por relatos
feitos à polícia
depois temos as redes mosquiteiras
também a outra grande diferenciação em
relação ao que existe é que não
utilizamos inseticidas ou as redes só
precisa isto é como a propriedade da
ocorrência e ao mesmo que haja algum
buraco na rede ainda mantém maura de
proteção de forma que as pessoas
consigam ficar protegidas outras
aplicações que temos é pra ir pra pouco
cara na roupa onde confere propriedades
para poder ficar com efeito do ps até
lavar novo
é também floridas papel no sentido ficar
também com efeito de repelência durante
cinco horas pós copa mosquitos temos um
aditivo para colocar na máquina de lavar
a doméstica e também temos outra coisa
que foi pensada para todas as pessoas
terem acesso tudo nos países com menos
conseguida da econômica em andamento em
áfrica quantas pessoas terão acesso a
uma máquina de lavar muito poucas
então desenvolvemos uma solução que tem
algo que tenha a ver que é colocar uma
dose numa bacia com água simples pois
não tem né ea partir daí poderá
introduzir a roupa agitará e com caras
cara e fica como foi tudo polícia até
lavar roupa 20 vezes
portanto uma nova enorme situações com
altas taxas de eficácia tanto superiores
a 90% e com efeitos até quatro anos
nomeadamente no que diz respeito a
tintas e vernizes
isto é um projeto longo em que nós
conseguimos um grande time vamos fazer
um grande investimento mas acima de tudo
muitas horas de trabalho muita
persistência e sobretudo acreditar
agora vamos ver um vídeo e chama
particular atenção ao time
a imagem quando se vêem duas mãos e vai
uma diferença do que uma mão com
proteção e sem proteção
acho que uma imagem vale mais que mil
palavras portanto é a diferença que a
gente consegue utilizando nesta
tecnologia
temos outras funções que aproveitámos
esta tecnologia nomeadamente para as aos
dias conseguimos remover uma solução
sobretudo para quem tem problemas na
zaga né
os ácaros são responsáveis por 85% das
pessoas que sofrem de asma soluções para
o edital é de cadernos atópicas
conjuntivite também quando conseguimos
mais uma vez não matando sendo amigos
também do ambiente conseguir uma grande
eficácia a nível preventivo soluções
também levou bactericida
queremos contribuir para diminuição
drástica das infecções hospitalares
ainda arias no expresso era a primeira
página 55 60 agravamento das mortes em
termos de infecções hospitalares é temos
funções a nível térmicas também querem
manter a madeira durante um período de
quatro anos com polenta o bicho da
madeira
temos soluções para silvia no sentido de
pedra poeta evitar as micoses temos uma
situação de perigo e ético fantástica
que conseguimos há um ano atrás
evitar a amputação dos dedos do pé com a
utilização do piúva não tem propriedade
né para o pé do atleta
conseguimos também as funções frieiras
esta é nossa para apoiar de produtos é
nossa tecnologia a funcionária é
portuguesa e é esse o nosso desígnio ok
muito obrigado a todos